how does your quote-unquote play the
game
play the games in terms of completing
the goal fit in with
jordan peterson's agreeableness in terms
of career
advancement is it a case of right time
right agreeableness so this comes from
jordan peterson
talking about how people that are
more agreeable have
less success in promotion
and salary than someone that is more
assertive
so it's a really good question because
this person is taking
what i talk about which is play the game
right and
and thinking that that means
agreeableness and it does to some extent
it absolutely does to some extent
and so so that's a this is a really good
question and the answer is that there's
a dichotomy to this
that they're like like all of life and
like all of business and like all of
leadership there's a dichotomy because
while while someone that is agreeable
like like very agreeable certainly has
less of a chance of career advancement
than someone that is assertive
right that makes sense like if you never
say hey i'll do that or hey let me let
me handle that project if you don't ever
do that
and someone says hey no i'll do this and
you go okay that's fine
and you we're gonna promote this guy oh
okay that's fine you know if you're that
agreeable well yeah it's gonna be
problematic but also
when ins when assertiveness turns into
overly aggressive
the chances of advancement start to go
back down again and when you take
someone that's
when you get to someone that is ultra
aggressive and rubs people the wrong way
and won't do any compromising that
person's going to be at the same pers
same level of advancement as someone
that's super agreeable or at least in
the same ballpark they'll be close
if they still have a job at all by the
way because someone that's you know
overly aggressive and won't compromise
with anyone and calls everyone out
the if they're the complete far end of
the spectrum opposite
to agreeableness that's going to be a
problem so
so when i talk about playing the game
i'm i'm definitely talking about
being agreeable because i'm telling you
to be more agreeable right when you
don't play the game it's like
hey we're going to think this we're
going to run this new project that's
project is stupid
well an agreeable person would say okay
well that sounds good where are we going
with this
now an agreeable person that's too
agreeable might go down the road of
something that's not a good plan
but if you're overly aggressive if
you're not playing the great game at all
you're not going to get past
go right so
when i say play the game i am talking
about being a girl now i was talking to
someone the other day who's pretty
hardcore and he was feeling some heat
from his boss in a company that i was
working with and he
wanted to fight back
i wanted to fight back hashtag resist
and you want to fight back you want to
go beyond that you want to go beyond
resist he wanted to go like
into the aggressive mode and
i told him don't fight back i said play
the game and he sort of got aggressive
because like i said he's pretty hardcore
guy he started getting aggressive with
me
and started saying like oh that's what i
should do now bow down
and kiss the ring i'm not going to do
that i'm a man right
he came at me with that with that angle
and then he said this which was
interesting
he goes you know he said something along
the lines but you wouldn't take this
kind of crap
why should i and i
stayed quiet for a minute and i heard
him say that and i was like oh you just
served me up a little softball
and then you know i took a big breath
and i'm like you have no idea
you have no idea the things that i have
done
the pride that i have swallowed the dumb
jokes i've laughed at the
idiotic plans i've supported the insane
lengths that i had to go through
throughout my career my entire career to
win
to win in the end that was my goal and
in order to win you gotta play the game
you gotta massage some egos you have to
accept some things that you normally
might not accept you have to eat some
humble ply
some from time to time and what you're
doing
and why you do those things is so that
you can build so that you can build
confidence with your boss
that's what you're doing so you can
build trust with your boss
and you do that so that in the end if
your boss
is not a good guy you can actually beat
the boss you can win
but you can't win if you don't play the
game you'll lose before you even start
so play the game that's what i told this
guy
right now
can you do you have to balance this yes
you absolutely do because
if you become a sycophant and you just
become a brown noser
am i talking about becoming a brown
noser no because if you do that
you're losing clout and influence with
your
with your team or with your subordinates
or with your peers
because you're brown-nosing the boss and
you're losing clout there
so you have to you and you won't win
because those guys are going to get
pissed at you
they're not going to support you so i'm
not saying you go
overboard you have to have balance you
have to know
when to say yes when to appease
when you know i built so much clout
i built clout by doing things that
people wanted me to do that like maybe i
was kind of a
weird project or they want me to try
some piece of equipment outside cool
yeah i'll try it we'll write you a good
report about it you know what i mean
like
oh yeah you want me to try some new
tactics cool we'll give it a try i in my
mind i'm thinking this is dumb
but you know what hey let's give it a
try oh you know what we it didn't work
as well as i
was hoping it would but you know here's
some points we took away from it okay
the guy at least
as opposed to saying that new tactic is
stupid
your plan is dumb okay i'm disagreeable
what's that going to get me it's not
going to get
i'm being too assertive i'm being too
aggressive
so you have to you have to balance it
you have to know when to tactfully stand
up and disagree with someone
instead of being totally agreeable all
the time and i'm not talking about being
agreeable
i'm talking about balance that's what
i'm talking about
and that's playing the game yeah so
playing the game
is not being
a submissive agreeable
baby right that's not that's not playing
the game
yeah playing the game is playing balance
is knowing when
is building trust it's it's doing some
dumb things
showing respect that's just playing the
game
and you're playing the game to win
that's what you're playing the game for
yeah yeah you yeah and
and i i get it you know like playing the
game you know maybe
got viewed as like being agreeable but
when jordan peterson talks about
agreeableness he's talking about a
personality
trait he's not talking about like some
action you took to do something you know
well yeah but agreeableness
has resulting actions if you're an
agreeable person yeah maybe
fully but when it comes when it stems
from a personality trait that means just
like how you said like you're going to
be agreeable
for the most part regardless like i
forget what the
the the other trait was is called about
you know success when he was talking
about that
but um nonetheless like if you're
talking you're talking about playing the
game
meaning sure you might have to display
some agreeableness every once in a while
to kind of size it when you have to or
when you you know when it's useful
that does not mean you're an agreeable
person as a personality change that's
true
way too two different completely
different things i'm definitely not
i'm definitely not saying that you're
going to be able to train your change
your personality yeah
because i'm not a very agreeable person
i agree with people all day long right
why because i'm trying to win
that's the point exactly right i
actually disagree with 89 of the things
that i hear on a daily basis
you know what i mean yeah i'm literally
trying to figure out right now as i'm
thinking about this
so many things i disagree with there's
two things that are going on number one
this is this is straight up number one
if you give me an idea
and i go that's dumb echo number one
i'm arrogant i'm not listening i'm i'm
shutting the idea out when
your idea might have some good traits to
it number two you're pissed
yeah right i didn't gather any clout
with you we i didn't build our
relationship at all
i just said like hey that's a dumb idea
no so instead of being like okay well
tell me about it
yeah tell me like how would you how
would you implement this idea of yours
because
maybe it could have some good benefit i
could see where you're coming from on
this
yeah well now i'm i'm building a
relationship and
you're thinking that hey this guy
listens to me and that's what i like in
someone i work with someone that listens
to me so those are the kind of things
that we're talking about i'm not talking
about changing your personality i'm a
disagreeable
i'm a disagreeable human being but i
don't show that very often
right i don't there's something i was
talking about i was talking about this
who was i talking to i forget who i was
talking to but i was talking about how
i never ever like there's some things
that really bother me
sure in the world and i never tell
anyone what they are
i will not i'll go to the gr maybe i'll
put like in my last will and testament
things that bothered
me but i would but
but but i don't tell anyone yeah why
well
the main reason is because when you're
in the teams and people know what
they're going to get
they're going to tear you up with that
thing so you will never i'll never say
it won't tell my kids i don't tell my
wife nothing
when something happens that really
really bothers me because i'm
disagreeable
i don't like that kind of stuff is it
like pet peeve ken stuff
or personality traits i don't like
the way people communicate sometimes i
don't like little pet peeves that i have
of things that people do that i don't
like
but no one knows any of them no one
knows that they're all deep
undercover and i will never tell anyone
what they are you wanna i feel like you
should kind of tell me
just so i avoid these things because i'm
very agreeable in that way yeah where i
don't wanna do that stuff like if i'm
saying
you know people say i don't know no i'm
saying know what i'm saying or like if i
say like i say like a lot do you not
like that is that one of the things
i'll never tell anyone i'll never tell
anyone
all right what these things all right
cool you're
you're the target list for you it's not
that big
i'm at low risk all right i'm still on
the radar though all right
hey man you know so yeah hey everyone
play the game
play the game i know it's everyone wants
it that's the funny thing is everyone
thinks like jock was a hardcore
you know take no crap from nobody looks
like no actually i'm gonna play the game
because you know why i'm gonna win
that's the difference i'm gonna win
yeah that was kind of part of your story
too when when when the guy was
was that a face-to-face thing when
you're talking you're talking about the
guys yes who said it was
so there was like a built-in assumption
right there when he said you wouldn't
take that
oh actually let me tell you what my life
has been like yeah and you
and of course they're looking at me now
and they're thinking well he just he
just
uh aggressively crushed everyone on his
rise to the top
right yeah it's like no not true at all
yeah maneuvered
yeah like played the game yeah nothing
wrong with playing the game
yeah now again this isn't we're not
talking about
like you just become a kiss ass that's
not what i'm talking about
yeah being a kiss ass is equally bad
yeah
it's equally bad you lose just as much
respect
not only from your peers not only from
your subordinates but also from the
the person that you're working with yeah
they even know you're a kiss ass
and they'll run roughshod all over you
and when it comes time promotion they're
like you know what i'm gonna
promote the other guy because it doesn't
really matter this guy was gonna be
gonna kiss my ass regardless yeah
because you're too you're too agreeable
yeah so i'm not talking about this this
is a dichotomy
yeah yeah that yeah man so you
again the point that i was making that i
think there might have been a
misunderstanding
given the question like play the game
isn't the same as this agreeableness
that jordan peterson is talking about
it's different they're not the same
thing
well no they're not yeah it seems like
the question that he thought
it was the same thing yeah he exactly he
thinks that playing the game is being
agreeable yeah
it's not yeah it might sometimes
be acting agreeable it might be agreeing
to some things that
make you a little bit frustrated yeah
but you roll with it
because you know what you're playing to
win you're playing the long game this is
a
joke this conversation we're having with
my with my boss or with my support
that's a joke that thing doesn't matter
to me yeah i don't care if i win this
argument
i'm playing the long game over here like
win you've watched survivor
no come on bro you ever watch survivor i
know i mean i've seen shows yeah yeah
yeah
yeah okay so i don't watch survivor well
i do i mean my wife does so
hence i think it's still on yeah
okay so survivor
playing the game and that's the term
that is all up
all up in survival playing the game so
okay once around take too long survivor
but
it's it's totally in line with what
you're talking about so
survivor you you know they throw and
here's what the basis
just the prime raw basis of surviving
you throw a bunch of people
on i know everyone knows the basic thing
yeah you do some challenges
you vote each other off with certain um
you know uh advantages you can win
and whatnot right rewards whatever
so and how it turned itself like
what it morphed kind of into just by
nature is like this little political
game within the game
right and now it's just a huge overt
part
of survivor the political game i'm
playing the game
i'm building alliances i'm doing all
this stuff or whatever it's this exact
same thing man
exact same thing yeah i'm building
relationships or whatever
yeah let me tell you what the huge
difference is
and this is a huge difference in that
game you're playing the game to win for
yourself
yeah and what i'm talking about and this
is a this is a
such a huge part of the way i think that
i didn't even talk about it because it's
just embedded in the way i think
if you're playing the game to further
yourself and further your own career
you're it's not going to work for you
yeah because when you play the game like
that it's the same thing as like kissing
ass it's the same thing as
you're doing things because you want the
advantage and people will identify that
if you're making if you're playing the
game so that your team can win so you
can accomplish the mission
that's when this works that's when
playing the game works otherwise if
you're doing it to promote yourself
it's not going to work and it might work
once or twice and it might get you one
promotion
but everyone that saw you get promoted
after you kissed ass they're all pissed
at you they're going to undermine you
and you're going to go down
bro you know what's so it's so
interesting about what you just said
there
is that you're absolutely right survivor
is like the one guy right
so playing the game i'm playing the game
right anytime someone says that like hey
i'm playing the game
they do it in this context where it's
like so and that's okay we're here it's
a game so it's acceptable i'm playing
the game
but they'll always say it in as an
excuse for like
lying to someone or backstabbing someone
and it's so weird how that you're
exactly right that's the nature of the
game so when you play the game in in
this conte you know and
at work or the way you're talking about
it's always a good thing
because as long as you're doing it for
for the team yes exactly right
so it's not always a good thing because
there's people that play the game and
they play the game so that
they are going to you know i've
i just said this 10 times like i played
a win but yeah i play for my team to win
i play for us to be able to accomplish
the mission yeah that's why i'm playing
the game
yeah if you're playing the game so that
you can get the promotion or
that's not going to and like i said it
might work once or twice but it's not
going to be it's not a long-term
solution
yeah guarantee is not a long-term
solution yeah that's a strong statement
i guarantee it's not a long-term
solution
yeah now what if you now here's an
example
just taking this one step further you
could play the game
to get that one promotion and then you
could go okay now i can play the game to
help the team right but you had to do
some maneuvering to get into a spot
where you could help
that's a tricky one because people still
think you're a jerk
right because of what you did yeah but
then you get there and it's going to
take you a long time to build that trust
back up because you maneuvered and you
got collateral damage around there yeah
it's not a good thing it's not hard to
clean up that collateral damage
yeah man so you can't always do it
actually
yeah be careful you know how you say
you'll lose a battle to win the war kind
of thing
so now in your little example there
right there you're like you you lost a
battle to win a little mini war to
essentially lose a bigger battle
to win even a bigger war these are
things that they have all this
just like in jiu jitsu you sacrifice a
position because you know you're gonna
end up
with a area of the game that you're
really good at yeah right
i mean what you think about pulling
guard what's pulling guard yeah that's
the yeah you're
sacrificing being on the bottom because
you're good at it yeah so yeah
for for a bigger victory yeah
this game goes deep man this stuff goes
deep indeed
playing the game